[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la raison pour laquelle je suis ici est de
te présenter Ashley - c'est juste très important
d'être qui tu veux être hé là, je suis
Ashley - c'est super de te rencontrer
Rachel ici - je serai  ici pour vous, je
serai là pour vous, elle ne comprend pas à
quel point toutes les affaires que vous pensez sont fragiles, je
devrais augmenter la dose, les assommer
vous-même devient si difficile de continuer à faire
cela,
c'est vraiment l'application qui dit que nous
devons le faire dans notre  pic de fertilité pour
économiser autant je ne sais pas si je peux je
saurai bien où je vais après mon départ d'
ici tu sais ce qui te concerne
parfois tu t'en vas en quelque sorte bien sûr
je t'aime aussi il se passe quelque
chose  quelque chose rentre à la maison c'est ce que j'ai
dit pas une minute rien ne se passe à
propos de
[Musique]
maintenant une fois de plus, retournez votre attention sur
le souffle de l'armée de l'air ouais
terminal 3 avez-vous travaillé à cet endroit en
mille morceaux ouais
le Sat Nav sonne un accident qui vous vient à l'
esprit  si je suis un itinéraire alternatif,
cela m'a montré que votre esprit peut simplement se demander
regarder
fumer
calmement et sans jugement
[Musique]
toi